thank you thank you all for being here
and I'm grateful to be invited to I keep
getting invited to these talks at a PI
data and Python conferences and I have
to say I've always found the Python
community of you really welcoming and
warm and supportive and in terms of
growth mindsets very much not threatened
by the the success of others so I think
I think we can say that python python is
a growth mindset kind of community so i
have sort of two positions i am two hats
i am one of the cofounders of julia
computing which is a company providing
support and training and consulting for
julia which is increasingly used and you
know finance insurance aerospace all
sorts of things i also have a part-time
position at the center for data science
at nyu so if anybody is at NYU and
interested in talking about you know
Julia using it getting involved let me
know I'm pretty easy to find on the
internet so so I'm gonna start out with
sort of a little bit of background
motivation what my data science stack
looked like back in two thousand nine
when I was doing data science but didn't
actually yet realize that I was a data
scientist because i think the term was
kind of coined like right around then or
at least that's what google trends tells
me so in a single project at the time i
was using matlab for numerical linear
algebra and machine learning this was
some singular value decomposition and
non-negative matrix factorization stuff
I was doing and MATLAB is a really great
tool for this so I that was pretty good
and of course I was in grad school so I
don't have to pay for it so that was
okay too i was using RF was just a
statistical analysis and for
visualization because uh the
visualization of matlab is just nowhere
near as nice as our and of course the
stats stuff is not not nearly as good
either but then there were some things
that needed to be written in c because
they needed to be really really fast and
efficient so i had some see in there and
then of course i was dealing with lots
and lots of data files lots of inputs
lots of outputs running simulations
doing all sorts of stuff shuffle it
around a cluster
and that any of that stuff is a
nightmare to do in any of these
languages so I also had Ruby to tie it
all together and I realized at this
point that I had created a Rube Goldberg
machine if you're not familiar with Rube
Goldberg he was an artist I think active
in like the 50s and 60s and you draw
these incredibly complicated machines
where like you know this guy is eating
and his spoon pulls a string which like
flips a piece of toast up and then the
parrot eats it and then that like makes
the parrot go down and then it put like
spills a bucket of water and yada yada
yada and eventually like something
useful happens but you know it's just
like cobbled together out of all of
these crazy pieces and that's what i
felt like i was doing now it wasn't
using Python at the time had I been
using Python or head Python been in the
state that it is now back in two
thousand nine maybe I would never start
it on the Julia project but but we'll
see i'll talk a little bit about that in
a bit so this is actually the for
language problem but we sometimes talk
about the to language problem and the to
language problem it actually goes under
another name that's older which is
austere holtz dichotomy and this is
after this was a term coined by John
Ulster Holt who was actually the creator
of tickle then he was familiar with that
programming language and he observed at
some point in like the 80s I think that
there seemed to be to like classes of
languages that were quite difficult are
quite different and that were sort of
you know what things gravitated towards
and they were systems languages and
scripting languages systems languages
are statically typed typically scripting
languages I Dana dynamically typed
systems languages are compiled scripting
languages are interpreted systems
languages have user-defined types like
you have a struct or something like that
that you can define and then do stuff
with scripting languages tend not to let
you do that and instead they provide a
couple of very rich standard data types
that you can do all sorts of different
things like link a dick right in Python
it's this one like really really
powerful data structure or pythons
arrays which are actually the get called
lists I don't know why that seems like a
mistake that should've been corrected
point but um you know you can use them
as a cue or a DQ or stack or all sorts
of like it's a very powerful array data
structure they also systems languages
also tend to be fast whereas the
scripting languages are slow systems
languages are hard whereas scripting
languages are easy so this is this is
the dichotomy and this was sort of the
state of affairs in like most most of
like the 80s and 90s and now in the like
to thousands we're starting to see that
dichotomy sort of come apart a little
bit we're seeing this this the systems
languages sort of take some of the the
properties of the scripting languages
and vice versa so because of this
dichotomy there's a standard arrangement
that people have typically used to do
things because you're like well you know
I want convenience but i also want
performance i want both of those things
and the compromise is that for
convenience use a scripting language at
the high level something like python or
our matlab but you do all of the hard
stuff in the systems language so when
you're using numpy for example like the
the fast stuff the stuff that's actually
doing stuff with arrays is all written
in c or actually Fortran right because
you're calling gloss if you do a matrix
multiply which is still written in
Fortran so that and that kind of works
like this is a pretty good arrangement
this has been sort of the state of the
art for 30 years or something like that
I have myself written many high-level
wrappers to low-level functionality and
then you know you're happy because you
can you can get the performance but you
get this nice ease of use to but it is
not a perfect arrangement it's very
pragmatic but it's got some issues so
one issue is aren't the hard parts
exactly where you could benefit from a
better language right so like why are we
doing the hard stuff in see that seemed
like kind of perverse right like I
actually did try to I was fixing us one
of our benchmarks because I noticed that
C was cheating and doing less work than
all the other programming languages and
took me like two hours to get this thing
not to crash I don't know what I was
doing I had forgotten how to do see
index incorrectly and see and I was just
like how god I'd forgotten how difficult
this was so so this is this is a real
issue this is you know c programming is
not super easy
it also forces vectorization everywhere
right there's this sort of like you're
trot pot that like for loops are kind of
immoral like it as it turns out there
just like impractical for people it
writing libraries and high-level
languages they're not actually a moral
right it's fine to write a for loop the
only issue is it's going to be slow if
you're in one of these high-level
languages you want to like push as much
work as possible into the low-level
language but sometimes it's really
awkward and you end up writing some very
strange convoluted code to try to do
this it also can often force like
additional memory allocation right
because you have to go through a lot of
create a lot of temporary erase in this
style whereas like in C or something you
would just like use one array and then
mutate it in place and that would be
fine and you would not ever create any
temporaries there's another subtler
issue that took me a long time to
recognize which is that it creates a
social barrier between users and
developers right so in these two
language systems the users use one
language they use the high level
language the developers actually don't
spend that much time programming in the
eye level language they spend a lot of
time programming the low-level language
and use it being a user of the high
level system doesn't make you better you
know qualified in any way to work on the
internals you kind of there's just a
barrier there right and I even fight
even though I'm like perfectly well
according to my story not that good at C
programming but like I've done a lot of
c programming I'm okay at it you know if
I'm using Python or are I tend to like
hit that sea wall and then I just
stopped because it's too much of a pain
to find out where the sea source code is
and how things work and I just kind of
even though I could I just don't so
maybe maybe that's the moral issue maybe
I should but but people don't it's just
not practical so Julie is a programming
language tries to crush and shatter this
oyster holds dichotomy when I we want to
have our cake and eat it too so you know
these are the two columns and we do this
we sort of take mix-and-match pieces
from both columns julia is dynamic but
it's compiled we let you have
user-defined types and standard type so
the standard types are pretty powerful
but you can also do your own
user-defined types and I'll show you an
example of that in a bit it's fast and
it's easy
how fast this is sort of the obligatory
performance chart this is time on a
bunch of sort of you know micro
benchmarks that aren't really super
interesting except that they time things
like how good are you at recursion
iteration scalar loops parsing integers
printing stuff you know doing a little
bit of matrix multiplication it's time
relative to see the the y-axis is
logarithmic so you know being higher up
is much worse and the languages across
the bottom Julia Fortran go JavaScript
Python Mathematica our matlab octave
python is sort of where you like that's
as good as a good interpreted languages
ought to be that's sort of where you are
but then you have these like compiled
languages like Fortran and go and then
julia is the odd man out because it's
sort of its dynamic but it's actually
within a factor of two of see
consistently beaten people actually see
the Sun real-life code to this isn't
just contrived from Mike Reuben I think
this is a much more interesting chart
this is the same y axis but the x-axis
is actually how many lines of code
normalized between whatever the minimum
and the maximum one was for each
benchmark each languages and you kind of
see these two regimes you have you have
a long you know you have this corner
right here these are the fast piled
language these are the system's
languages these are the scripting
languages so you have this kind of
choice you like saw you can be up on
this end of the curve or on this end of
the curve you can either be concise and
slow or you can be fast and kind of
verbose of course there's one point
that's sort of in the corner here so
that's where we want to be I like I like
being in that corner so this is my data
science stack today Julia for numerical
linear algebra statistical analysis yeah
he's Julie for everything Python can
give you a lot of this right like you
could use Python for everything but the
c line right so it gets you down to from
four line
which is 22 but to get all the way down
to one language you need to do more and
project sleep I are sort of like pushing
in that general direction so maybe in
the future people will be using pi PI
and like writing Python code and it'll
be like fastest see so that's exciting
um so for the rest of this talk i am
going to give you some examples i'm
going to do a lot of live coding and you
know things might go horribly wrong
hopefully they won't i'm gonna demo how
you can use julie as a general perfect
language so not just a language for
numerical computing although i'm going
to give a numerical example but you know
whatever you can also use it for data
analysis the usual stuff like data
frames and then plotting some stuff and
then i'm going to show what hopefully is
a compelling example of a superpower for
a user and then Anna compelling example
of how it gives superpowers to library
writers too and so that's that's that
I'm going to do in the Jupiter notebook
so everybody familiar with the Jupiter
notebook this is a Python audience so I
assume so everybody knows about this
right this used to be called the ipython
notebook but now it supports like 40
languages or something like that as
kernels Julia I think was the first like
real usable back a colonel aside from
Python fernando pérez invited me and
jeff and some of the other julia
contribute contributors to come to
berkeley and write this kernel and we
went and did it was a fun week ok so
this is this is what Julia code looks
like you can do things you can say that
max iterations is constant and then you
define you can have a doc string it
actually goes outside the function
instead of inside that actually makes
sense in Julia but I won't get into why
and you notice that I don't really put
any types or anything on here I just say
you know the dude this is not this is
the Julia set that I'm going to compute
doesn't really have anything to do with
the name but whatever it's a cute
coincidence so you take two complex
numbers Z and see and then what you do
is you do this iteration step this Z you
say Z equals Z squared plus C and keep
doing that until it escapes beyond the
radius of 2 and the number of tot like
iterations you have
do before thing escapes it gives you
like a color which you then can
visualize it and make pretty pictures
which we're about to see so you just you
know press shift enter and that
evaluates the cell and you can see that
you got a generic function now call
Julia with one method and we can you
know call it on one complex point and
you can see I'm a little too tall for
this podium so I'm going to put this up
here we can see some other points like
okay that's a higher point I don't know
so takes more iterations to escape we
can do this with a comprehension of
two-dimensional array comprehension
syntax here so this is similar to
pythons one-dimensional array
comprehension syntax but you can do
arbitrarily many dimensions and get in
this case a matrix so this is a matrix
of the escape times across a certain
range I chose the range so that at least
some of the numbers were interesting and
they weren't all twos but you can you
can see this is 501 by a thousand
thousand and one alright well that's
kind of a you know a lousy way to
visualize things so let's actually load
some packages that do more interesting
visualization the first thing I'm going
to do is define a color map which is
it's the color this this package colors
provides a couple of different built in
color maps with this one's going to
involve red and blue I'm going to get a
hundred points because max iterations
was 100 so I'm going to go from 1 to 100
and then I'm going to use that color map
to turn escape times I see if you
evaluate the color map it prints it
nicely you can see the colors it's
actually just an array of colors but the
we know how to print that as a nice
thing and you can see here now I make an
image out of it and you get this pretty
picture can people see that reasonably
well on the projector I think okay cool
one of the interesting things about the
Julia set is that you change these
numbers a little bit you change the
starting point a little bit and get kind
of radically different things and you
get a lot of different really
interesting pretty pictures but you know
going in there Oh another interesting
thing about it is that doing it that way
is the Julia set if you take this so
this is essentially a four dimensional
shape because it's too complex numbers
as inputs which are each two dimensional
if we take the diagonal of this set it
is the Mandelbrot set so that should
probably be familiar to people so the
Julia set and the Mandelbrot set are
related in this kind of this kind of way
but it's interesting to sort of explore
this set so let's use this thing called
interact which gives you you can take
anything that so that expression I I
used to generate an image I can actually
just say put this macro in front of it
at manipulate is a macro in Julia and
give it a range for sliders and then
we're actually going to be able to like
you'll see in a second you can scrub the
sliders around and get different images
all right so now we've got that and we
can change it which is this is a much
nicer way to explore different things
and you can see that it kind of gives
you gives you different patterns and
their / they're all quite beautiful so
this is a little more sluggish than I
would like so one of the things this is
doing is this is generating a new array
every single time and going through in
you know and then constructing an image
out of it this is sort of inefficient it
would be nice if I could just
pre-allocate one chunk of memory and
just redisplay that every single time
and not have to like you know go through
all this memory allocation because
that's expensive so this is a version of
that which is slightly more verbose but
does exactly that so I use a let block
to say that what these INR are so that I
can actually use their length that's
just kind of nice so what I do is I
create a data array and here you see one
of the particularly Julian things we
don't shy away from talking about types
so classically dynamic languages try not
to talk about types they sort of try to
pretend they don't exist
we decided that you know the first thing
I mean the whole like the whole initial
point of numb pile is to have like typed
arrays in Python which is the Sun typed
language and so in numerical computing
inevitably you end up having to talk
about type so let's just have one good
system for talking about types and make
that universal so it's actually just
baked into the language and the language
knows about types so here we're
constructing a two-dimensional array a
matrix the element types are the
elements are actually this RGB type with
an unsigned fixed point 8-bit value in
there but you don't have to know about
but this is all sort of like custom
types that are just defined in libraries
but they actually have the exact
representation you would like for the
machine which is you can represent RGB
values is just like you know triples of
aid but of 8 bits then you create this
image and then you just sort of go over
and instead of instead of constructing
the thing every time we just take a for
loop and go through and just update the
image every time for loops are not evil
in Julia at least they're not going to
be slow they're actually going to be
quite fast so now we can see that we can
we can scrub through this and it's
significantly more responsive which is
quite nice cool any questions about that
so far all right cool all right so
fractals are cute but you know we're
here for analyzing data not analyzing
fractals so let's do a little bit of
data analysis I'm going to load this
package called data frames which
provides a data frame data type you know
very similar to the one that ships with
our and very similar to the one that
pandas provides so I'm going to load
this jared jared is here somewhere this
is one of jared's data sets that i
actually you know just played with at
some point was like oh this is a nice
data set it's good for displaying them
demonstrating things NYC housing it's
got a bunch of columns about like
different housing sales throughout the
city and you can see that the type of
this thing is that at the data frame and
then I'm going to use this package
called gadfly which is similar to the
it it's a grammar of graphics style
visualization package in pure Julia and
when I say in pure Julia I mean like the
whole thing is written in Julia there is
no C code involved which is kind of nice
it means you can hack on it more easily
but it from a user's perspective it kind
of doesn't matter so ok the first
obvious thing you want to do is I'll get
rid of the headers so that we can see a
little more I don't know plot some stuff
so like square gross square foot versus
estimated expense that should have some
sort of interesting relationship right
when we look at this and it's kind of
this like diagonal blob and you're like
well yeah I guess maybe that has a
relationship so I don't know the first
obvious thing to do here is like there
are really big values and there are
really small values and a lot of stuff
concentrated in the little small very
small value so let's you know let's
scale it to be log-log scale so this is
this is how you add attributes if you're
familiar with ggplot this is sort of
similar to the way ggplot works ok now
we're getting somewhere there you go
it's you can it's like pushed pulled
everything out of that like far left
corner we'd we now actually have things
kind of spread out in a nice clean way
still not like a little bit would be
nice two separate things out so one of
the things you can do is you can color
by one of the fields and I'm going to
color by borough and you can see that
now ok yeah color by borough this is
getting a little interesting and we can
zoom in a bit and you can see that yeah
so Manhattan is the blue up across the
top and Manhattan is like significantly
more expensive you're sort of higher up
for long this log log scale then you
know say Brooklyn is next and then
Queens and then the Bronx and Staten
Island I mean you're I bet a lot of
people here from New York City this
makes sense
I mean so you can do you can do other
things pretty straightforward stuff like
plotting a histogram of you know so
since we we figured out that like you
know its income and square footage thing
or have this log log relationship you
know if we take a relay to take a ratio
that should actually give us give us
some like fairly consistent stuff so we
can take a histogram plotting by color
of these things and you can see again
like you know there's there's kind of
two modes for Manhattan and then
Brooklyn is sort of further down
branches you know further down is this
the same same data just sliced a
different way so yeah you can do data
analysis pretty straightforwardly I I
think that's you know that's useful it's
obviously interesting and like necessary
that you can do this but this is not one
of the things that sets it apart because
you can do this kind of data analysis in
any of these tools so I'm going to talk
about some of the other things the
things I think give you real like super
powers so the next thing I'm going to
talk about this is super powers for
users this example this guy Patrick Usul
dinger I assume that as a German name he
emailed because and we get this a lot
this happens is pretty typical like I
wrote Python code and I poured it to
Julia and it wasn't faster what am i
doing wrong or you are a liar because
you said this would be fast depends i
prefer the you know the former but the
other thing happens to and unfortunately
our mailing lists are full of people who
are like love hacking performance right
so this is always like this is always
kind of fun because everyone is just
like oh yeah here are several like cool
ways you can make this much faster and
like frequently it's like orders of
magnitude faster by the time you get
done so in this case it was an
interesting journey and performance
because they're a couple of like the
original so the original Python version
took point five seconds to compute this
to figure out these kokoro poke puzzles
are sort of they're like we look them up
yeah sort of this cross between a su
doku and a crossword and you have these
like sums of digits in the corners and
you're supposed to use that to figure
out like fill in the digits in the
middle of the puzzle I've never played
these but it's obviously like a nice
little math puzzle that you can solve so
he was writing a thing to solve these
the Python version took PI point five
seconds to solve the original naive
Julia thing that he'd written was
thirteen point four seconds and then
with some minor tweaks it got down to
like point nine seconds but then people
kept sort of whittling away that was
mostly just like don't you know the
Python version was it was pushing stuff
onto arrays where the other one was like
creating a new ever a every loop so
you're like yeah okay allocating a new
array every time is going to be slow but
we can also push on to the ends of a
race so that's not a problem and then
this this guy Jason Merrill who's been
around our community for a long time
came like got into this and like really
really optimized the heck out of it and
he got it down to 13 microseconds which
I was just like okay yeah we get like
sometimes orders of magnitude
performance improvements but that's like
ridiculous that's six orders of
magnitude so how do you get a million
EXPEED up on this so the original
version I'm not going to show you the
code for the original version but you
can imagine what it's doing it's like
making a raise of digits and then sort
of doing stuff to sum them whatever and
the breakthrough that that the Jason had
was he realized well hey the in this
language it's actually really easy to
make custom data types that are
extremely efficient but also convenient
to work with so why don't I just make a
custom data type for this digit set
thing because it's doing all these
digits set operations so he creates a
digit set type which is immutable which
means it can't be changed which lets the
compiler do nice things with it it's
also typical for like numerical things
you want them to be immutable because
they're sort of identified by their
value not by some location in memory
there's sort of sort of like philosophy
about that but I think the easiest way
to see why immutability might be nice is
that there was a bug in an early Fortran
compiler where you could mutate the
value of integers because it actually
stored integers the same way it stored
other variables
so too was just like a name for a
location in memory that happened to have
the value to add it and the bug was that
you could change it so you could write
two equals three and then for the rest
of the program to was three and like
that's obviously crazy you do not want
to do that you can have similar fun in
Python 2 by changing the values true and
false that is allowed they fix that in
in Python 3 so you know this is there's
there's certain things that really
should be identified by their value if
you change if you change the like
imaginary part of a complex number you
don't have that complex number didn't
change you have a different complex
number right whereas with like a raise
for example like you can have the notion
of an array containing different stuff
at different times is coherent that
makes sense the array is like a
container all right so we define this
immutable digit set and the observation
here is that to represent a set of
digits 1 through 9 you only need 9 bits
right and so an 16 suffice a--'s that
gives you plenty of room to work with
different subsets of digits and then the
rest of this stuff is just ways to
construct a digit set from an array the
iteration protocol so you know python
has an iteration protocol you can make
this thing iterable and Julia to the lot
the length so the length of a digit set
is you count the number of ones in the
bit representation of it and this is a
one instruction thing on x86 I'll show
you some some x86 code in a second I
know you're excited and then how to show
the thing so it's nice and usable and
then some set operations so Union
intersection sim diff and set diff and
these are just defined in terms of ands
and ORS of int of the int field that's
inside so let's evaluate this create one
I should actually I should clear all the
output to add suspense all right so
there we created a digit set so you can
see here that we can do things like
oops the Union we can also use unicode
union you can also write Union but we
the unicode union is an alias for the
other thing so you can see the union of
these two sets you can see the
intersection no it's not it's called cap
inlay tech these are the latex capes so
you see the intersection 356 I don't
think that there is a fancy Unicode
symbol for the symmetric difference but
that's the symmetric difference between
the two so here's what's nice check out
the code for this ok so the native code
for that is so that the first three
instructions are actually just like
stuff like set up for the function and
the last two are just how you return
from a function the only thing that
actually does anything here is this one
or double or word instruction which is
the x86 instruction for for oaring to 16
bits bit things together and you can see
the same thing for the code the code
native for the intersection is just that
same thing except with an and and the
sim diff it's an X or so I mean this is
pretty slick this is very nice yeah so
anyway also the count ones let's see
what count ones i haven't actually tried
this one but let's see so length of a is
five ok code native oh no we blew it on
that one that's lousy codegen yeah can I
have to file a file an issue and fix
that yes
oh yeah okay well i mean we ought to be
able to do better than this though ok so
now now that we've got so the nice thing
about this is you can see that you
interact with this thing as though it
was just this array but it's actually
represented with this incredibly
efficient encoding and all the
operations are incredibly efficient so
this is like this is one of the like the
mantras of Julia's zero cost abstraction
get a real nice abstraction but there is
no cost to it whatsoever and that makes
doing you know math stuff a lot a lot
easier because you get the you want to
think in one level and you want the
computer operated a very different level
and then you just need to connect those
two so now you can just make this thing
a lookup table because there really
aren't that many of these combinations
so here's the code to do that and then
you can for example look up this guy and
it is a 12 element array of digit sets
this is kind of cute the size of s that
array is 24 bytes so it's two bytes per
and there's 12 of them so this is 24
bytes to represent each of these one of
these things now doing the decomposition
thing is just the lookup and so we
benchmark it and so the first time you
benchmark it the first time you run
something it does jit compilation so
remember I said Julie is dynamic but
it's compiled that means that the first
time you run something you compile it so
it's going to it's going to allocate
some memory because the compiler runs
it's going to take a little bit of time
but you know you run things more than
once the second time it's 10 10
microseconds to actually do this
computation that was taking 13 seconds
before and it's you know there's some
variation but that's it oh one thing I
wanted to show this Julia set code so
the code native for this is just like a
page full of instructions x86
instructions so that is this is pretty
fast like and this is you know this is
actually if you look at how this is
defined so you know for example let's
say we wanted to add two complex numbers
so 1.5 plus 2m
+ 2.5 plus 3 m's so that's adding two
complex numbers you know which of course
works let's say you want to see which
method does that so the the plus
function is actually this generic
function with 206 methods we can look at
what the methods are like that takes a
little while because there's a lot of
them and you can see that this is all
the ways of adding things that Julia
knows about this would sort of be baked
into the compiler in most systems but we
actually just defined it in Julia you
can actually click on a link here and it
takes you to the exact commit on github
that you are currently running to the
line where it was defined and you can
see that the way it's defined is that
you want to add two complex numbers you
add the real parts and they're imaginary
parts and you just make a new complex
number out of it but that still boils
down to that's like very high level of
abstraction these are this is a
parametric type you're like going
through many layers of dispatch but it
still boiled down to just like a couple
of instructions this also this is what I
was talking about with like breaking
down barriers right like the social
barrier like not only is it available
but like you click a link and you can
see exactly where its defined and you
could change it if you wanted to it
would break stuff if you try changed it
but like you know but you can yeah so
anyway uh so that's that's okay so now
the final thing I'm going to demo is
this is going to get a little a little
more technical but I kind of I think I
think we can handle it I think it'll be
okay so this is an efficient
implementation of Savitsky goal I
smoothing has anyone heard of this I had
not heard of it until next last week but
someone came up with this is a really
good example of this we do a lot of
stage programming in Julia so macros are
a form of stage programming jit is also
a form of stage programming we have this
new thing called generated functions
which is a like really unusual but
really nice form of stage programming
essentially lets you at the point where
the compiler is figured out the types
that it's going to call a function on
but you can actually hook in and be like
oh yeah for those types I'm
going to tell you what code to use for
those particular combination of types
and you can generate the code using
Julia and then run it so I'm going to
show you how this works so what we do is
we we define a type for this filter the
Savitsky book the live filter oh I can't
I get out of restart the colonel there
we go alright so i define a type for
this it doesn't actually have any fields
because the only useful information is
the type parameters which are m and n m
is the like the window the half size of
the window oh that you're smoothing and
n is how many moments you want to
preserve so the thing about the civets
giggle i filter is it preserves the
moments of your data so the first
central moment second central moment
which is basically like the mean the
variants and like then higher up would
be like the skewness and the kurtosis so
you can smooth the data while preserving
those properties of it which is a pretty
nice thing this was like a paper when it
came out an important paper that had
never heard of until last week so here's
what we do this is the actual function
the code that does this and this is
going to be a little bit crazy looking
but it's actually doing this in any
other system that i know of would be
like 10 like a hundred times crazier so
what this says is this says okay if you
if if I would like to generate a filter
for this for a particular mnn on data of
some type and smooth and smooth output
so we're going to write the we're going
to smooth the data in data and put it
into the array smooth which has been
pre-allocated by someone else for us and
what you need to do to like to figure
out how to do this smoothing is you
actually need to construct a Jacobian
matrix and then do a saul the backslash
which is like linear least squares
solution and then that tells you the
coefficients for smoothing the
coefficients for smoothing don't depend
on the data though they just depend on
like how many moments you want to
preserve and how the wide your window is
so that's why this is a good target for
this and essentially what we're going to
do is we're going to generate like the
optimal looped code that you could
possibly write for this by hand for a
particular m and n but we're going to do
it as soon as you actually want to call
that and I will show you that so this is
the code that generates the code that
then runs which you'll see in a second
it's easier when you see the actual
that runs that's just some convenience
methods the data here is just going to
be a range from one to a thousand it's
not even like an actual materialized
array it's just a range object but it
works it doesn't matter we'll
specialized for that so now we're going
to do a three-wide filter which means
that three before and three after is
what we're going to use for our
smoothing and the four means we want to
preserve at least four central moments
and we're going to apply it to the data
and we'll see what happens here okay and
it's taken a second so the reason it
takes a second it's good as generating
the code and then compiling that code if
we do it again it's fast and you can see
that it you know kind of kind of vaguely
looks like the input data but it is you
know it sort of flanges at the ends and
it does some other stuff in the middle
and actually so in this generation code
I did here right here I save the
expression that I generated into a
global so that I could take a look at it
later so what I did there is I actually
generated this code so this is the code
that was generated bat function and this
is what's actually running and so you
see we spliced in the actual
coefficients that were computed based on
m and N and so that this is the actually
important part this is the branch free
middle of this that runs on most of the
data this is just a little fix-up at the
beginning because you're actually
running off the edge of the array and we
just wrap around and the same thing at
the bottom but you want to separate
those out otherwise you you have
branches in your inner loop and it's
just going to be a nightmare for
performance this is the fast way to do
it and so now we can see you can time
this thing so the first time it takes a
while because we're doing that code
generation and then the second time it's
50 microseconds I haven't timed this
against anything else because i don't i
don't have on hand a good library that
does this sort of smoothing but i think
that's fast I don't know sci-fi hasn't
no okay we'll have to do a comparison
see how that goes and the interesting
thing here too is you can look at oh I
forgot to load stats base there we go
you can compare the moments and you can
see that the the first pair of moments
you know
so the left-hand side is the Act moments
of the actual data the right hand side
of the moments of the smooth data you
can see that you know negative 1 point 4
times 10 to the negative 15th is almost
zero eight you know 83,000 and then you
know almost zero and then 1.25 times ten
to the tenth so we are actually
preserving pretty close the first four
central moments and then we sort of like
trail off and don't quite make it
anymore which was not guaranteed so for
was the what we actually wanted so the
cool thing here is that like so let's
say I want to do something with like you
know a width of seven for smoothing and
I want to do five central moments
because like whatever I just call this
and now you know it goes ahead and does
that and we can see that the expression
that it used was this other crazy
expression here in most systems I don't
know how you would do this like I don't
know how you would stage this
programming like in c++ you could do
this but you have to pre compile all the
combinations that you might ever want
which is a real pain because you might
not know until runtime what like
combinations you actually want or you
know and what you can't do this is a
library in C++ you have to do it as a
template and then that's you know that
means you need a C++ compiler to even do
this in other systems I think you could
do this but it just won't be efficient
so this I think gives you a nice
marriage of efficiency and usability
also the nice thing is that from the
user perspective this is the library
right respective I can see that this is
like a little bit you're like you could
be looking at this and be like a little
scary from a user's perspective you
don't need to know any of this like this
thing just works it's just a function
and it's just fast and that's all so I
think that is that is a pretty that's a
pretty nice thing anyway I think oh one
thing I wanted to end with if you go to
Julia box org all you need is a Google
sign-in we could expand it to other
things but that's what we got so far and
you can just use Julia in a
a for free in a notebook I don't know
why this is taking so long to load there
we go and there's actually there's a
there's a tutorial and you can just sort
of evaluate stuff it's notebook format
so you don't really have to think much
you just kind of let go through and
evaluate stuff and then you can play
with it so I have a bunch of stuff in
there but you can start here with like
you know start the tutorial and you can
just run code so you know the first
thing you do try is like one plus one
equals two you know R and you get a
different random number every time you
do this and then you can click through
to like the basics so I encourage
everybody to try this out give it a shot
even if you're not interested in doing a
project just yet give Giuli a try and
see how you like it thank you have time
for questions I me to take that as a yes
I mean I guess the closest would be like
MATLAB or Ruby it's definitely in the
the algal school with like the end end
blocks Pascal also had similar syntax
it's nice when you're cutting and
pasting things because that can get kind
of gnarly in Python yeah it's when you
so like it statically compiled languages
it's you compile everything and then you
run and those are completely set cleanly
separated in classic dynamic languages
there's no compilation so it's just all
runtime stage programming is where you
interleave compilation and execution in
various ways yeah
yeah yeah yeah you can there's a package
called pie call which lets you maybe I
should demo it I don't know uh III can't
I'm not enough time to demo it but like
yes you can do zero copy sharing of
between numpy and Julia it the package
was written by Steve Johnson who was
also the author of fftw which probably
people have heard of it's like this
insanely good FFT library that you've
all used Eve whether you know it or not
and he's just amazing and the stuff he
did with that package is just incredible
you can call back and forth for example
between Julia and Python functions
recursively and it just works like not
recommended but it works so it's as good
as see typically so to the extent that
those systems are as good as see I guess
they're comparable to the extent but
they're not then it's not comparable I
think that you know there were very much
trying to do similar things one of the
nice things i think that Julia gives you
is that this is the standard semantics
like you don't have to opt into a
different compiler a different
potentially different behavior like the
normal behavior that everyone tested
their program with is the one that's
fast of course the downside is it's a
different language so if you're really
set on using Python those other things
are going to do that and julia is
definitely not design answer your
question okay
yeah yes but it's not like Lua where
it's like a real small component that's
going to be easy to embed it's like I
mean with this is like everything in the
kitchen sink we're working on that we're
gonna we're stripping it down and
targeting embedded infra straight into
in like embedded architectures but for
now it's like it's a ton of stuff but if
you're willing to load a ton of stuff
then yes you can't embed it cool great
thank you much thank you